واحده من المعابر الحدوديه الاثني عشر
التي حددتها حكومه جنوب السودان لاستقبال
الفارينه من الاشتباكات المسلحه في
السودان حيث استقبلت هذه المنطقه حتى الان
15 الف شخص نصفح من مناطق دارفور المختلفه
والنصف الاخر مواطنون من جنوب السودان
اليوم جينا
وشاهدنا الموجود طبعا ده نكته
الموجود
ولقينا ده حاجه ماساويه
اولا لقينا
اللاجئين من اخواننا من السودانيين
عدد كبير جدا فوقه 7000 نفر
والعايدين فوق سبعه نحن بنتكلم عن عدد
اكواخ من المواد المحليه شيدح الفارون
لتكون مساكن بديله لهم مساكن لن تقيهم من
لسعات الشمس الحارقه او تحميهم من حصول
الامطار الغزيره
احنا
[موسيقى]
ولكن يبدو ان البقاء تحت هذه الظروف قد
يخلق وضعا كارثيا اذا لم تتدخل المنظمات
الانسانيه لانقاذ ما يمكن انقاذه مبيور
شيرلو لقناتي العربيه والحدث حدود جنوب
السودان مع السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقاريط الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات